14 glücklose monate waren sie das frauen
duo an der spitze der link am tag als
susanne hennig welt so zurücktritt sind
die augen eigentlich auf sie gerichtet
janine wissler der jüngste sexismus
skandal betrifft ihren landesverband
vorwürfe betreffen ihren ehemaligen
lebensgefährten ich wälze abgang darf
auch als signal an die andere verstanden
werden gehe auch du whistler aber glaubt
bleiben zu können eine vertraute von
hennig welt so fordert nun offen bis las
rücktritt ich glaube dass man es
forscher natürlich sehr viel
verantwortung trägt die sind ja auch
sehr offensiv nach vorne gegangen und
haben beide gesagt dass er die partei
verändern wollen und dieses projekt ist
derzeit einfach gescheitert und deswegen
denke ich natürlich dass beide personen
auch die verantwortung dafür tragen
müssen es gibt in der linken seitdem der
spiegel vor einer woche missbrauchs
vorwürfe öffentlich gemacht hat der
parteivorstand entscheidet heute der
gesamte vorstand wird im juni neu
gewählt
bis dahin bleibt janine wissler chefin
einer partei die aufklären muss auch das
eigene rolle in den vorwürfen von hessen
den vorwurf der vertuschung
interviews gibt sie nicht nur ein
statement
deshalb alle konkreten fälle müssen
jetzt auf den tisch und sie müssen so
gut wie möglich aufgearbeitet werden das
will der parteivorstand jetzt machen und
das will ich jetzt machen dem fühle ich
mich verpflichtet
woanders ist das rücktritts signal von
hennig welt so angekommen nicht so
weitermachen als sei nichts gewesen im
linken jugendverband sollen sie hennig
welt so respekt und sind gleichzeitig
wütend auf ihre partei die offenbar
jahrelang sexismus geduldet hat
jetzt jugendverband wissen gerade von
bundesweit über 60 betroffenen die
vorwürfe von sexueller gewalt von
parteimitgliedern der linken vor bringen
das sind funktionäre dabei das und
mandatsträger dabei
und gerade deshalb wird es ebenso oft
unter den tisch gekehrt alles auf den
tisch das galt auch nach dem 4,9 debakel
bei der bundestagswahl
passiert ist nicht viel am wahlabend
selbst sagt wißler interviews abhängig
welt so hält ihr gesicht hin für eine
niederlage die eigentlich diese beiden
als spitzenkandidaten zu verantworten
haben
susanne hennig welt so wollte die partei
programmatisch erneuern verjüngen
regierungsfähig machen und macht sich
vor allem viele feinde den machtkampf
hat sie verloren ihr rücktritt freut die
die partei anders aufstellen wollen
weil damit natürlich auch die neuwahlen
eingeleitet werden die ich eigentlich
auch immer wollte und insofern ist der
rücktritt von danny will so ist wirklich
eine chance für die partei
fraktionschef bad versucht nun im
führungskampf macht zu demonstrieren
gibt zu verstehen dass wissler im amt
bleibt weil auch er sie noch hält
janine wissler ist gewählte
parteivorsitzende ist mitglied meiner
fraktion wie im übrigen susanne
honeywell so auch weiter und sie hat
jetzt wie andere die aufgabe die
anstehenden parteitage vorzubereiten
doch auch bad gerät unter druck
forderungen auch nach seinem rücktritt
werden laut wir brauchen auf allen
ebenen das hinterfragen von personal und
von inhalten und strukturen und das
bedeutet selbstverständlich auch dass
die fraktionsführung eine neue
legitimation braucht chaostage bei den
linken eine ist gegangen die die noch da
sind wollen im amt bleiben mit aller
macht